I've opened dev tools, and
I'll start my investigation by
taking a look at their actual sizes.
Looks like the first image
is 1000 x 667 pixels, and
the second image is
also 1000 x 667 pixels.
So at least their
resolutions are the same.
In the network tab, it becomes pretty
clear that they have different
compression levels, because the first
image has a size of about 60 KB.
While the second is only around 40 KB.
And both images pretty much look the
same so that's a lot of wasted bytes.
Saving with quality set to high can
be even more of a problem on mobile
where bandwidth is scarce and
the screens are small.
Later in the course, you'll learn
how to serve different images for
displays of different sizes and
different resolutions.